good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet so
to help you on your journey today's
message is be who you are born to be
over to you Michael Jordan it's not
about two shoes
[Music]
it's about knowing where you're going
not forgetting where you started it's
about having the courage to fail
[Music]
[Applause]
not breaking when you're broken taking
everything you've been given and making
something better
it's about work
before glory
and what's inside of you
what they say you can
it's not about the shoes it's about what
you do in there
it's about being we were born to be
Michael Jordan did with who was born to
do he found what he was born to do and
the unique thing about it was he found
it and then he actually took action on
it and he worked hard at it it wasn't
just I'm naturally gifted at this and so
I can coast and achieve some kind of
results
he took the work to find the thing that
he was great at and he put in the effort
consistently to become an icon and his
chosen profession and it's great and we
look up to him and and I use Michael
Jordan as an example a lot of my videos
and he's perhaps the greatest basketball
player of all time but you are no less
an icon you are no less great at
something I believe that we all have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and that's what you need to find and you
either haven't found it yet because you
haven't done enough exploring to find
the thing that you're great at or you
haven't put in the effort to get really
really good at it you have this thing
that you have potential to be the
Michael Jordan of in your field and
you're kind of coasting on it you're not
putting in the work you're not
practicing your jump shot and your free
throws and getting to the gym whatever
that equivalent is and you're in the
street I like to say that Michael Jordan
is not the greatest basketball player of
all time as an example and they say that
the greatest basketball player of all
time is a manager at Starbucks because
that person that guy at Starbucks who's
a manager now should have played
basketball but he either never picked up
a ball he never explored enough to find
out what he was great at or he never
practiced and I think if you don't know
what you will have Michael Jordan level
talent act then you need to explore so
often we discount things that could
immensely serve us without even trying
because it goes against our culture it
goes against how we you know what was on
our radar at the start like I never
thought I was gonna be an entrepreneur
just I didn't have unto her as my family
didn't we didn't talk about
entrepreneurship growing up it wasn't
something I was ever on my radar and so
I never thought I was gonna be an
entrepreneur and I had the good fortune
to connect with two entrepreneurs in
university and and joined their business
and being owner in that and learned
about entrepreneurship even though I had
all these entrepreneurial tendencies
growing up and I would be probably
working at some Bank and hating my job
if I didn't go down that entrepreneurial
path I would be the manager at Starbucks
instead of being the entrepreneur that I
want to be and so if you don't know what
you are great at you don't know what you
have that genius level talent out then
you need to go and start to explore try
stuff say yes when somebody invites you
to something say yes and go do it
instead of coming up with all the
reasons why it's never gonna work out
all the reasons why this is not a good
fit for you just say yes and try it how
many times have you discounted something
in your head because you've run through
the analysis without ever actually
taking action and saying yes or
something so if you're insanely happy
life is amazing you have the career you
want and the life you want and the
friends you want and the family you want
everything is amazing great you don't
have to do any of this
keep doing what you're doing because
life is amazing but if you're not happy
if you haven't found the thing that you
love yet if your relationship isn't
perfect and your business isn't perfect
and you are daily unhappy don't sit
there and complain and don't sit there
and just dismiss ideas that can help you
grow because it might be scary or new
and foreign and different to you just
say yes and try it don't be that manager
at Starbucks who never picked up the
basketball and could have been the
greatest basketball player of all time
be Michael Jordan explorer say yes try
it see if it makes you come alive if it
does do it again if not stop it and go
do something else you have Michael
Jordan level talent at something and I
want you to find it so the question date
today is do you know what you have
Michael Jordan level talent at and if
you do what is it leave it down the
comments below really curious to find
out also if you live a comment within
the first couple hours of this video you
have a good chance of winning one of our
two daily prizes I also want to give a
quick Shara to DiCarlo got an yani thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word really really means a
lot to remain and I hope you're enjoying
the read thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso
this prey so give me go
nothing fails like success you're
successful maybe it's in your health
maybe it's in your finances maybe it's
in your career maybe it's in your family
life maybe it's in the way that you show
up in the world awesome you're in a
really vulnerable place right now it is
one thing to be successful it is another
thing to sustain success over the coming
decades is that it not a powerful idea I
mean let's go to the entertainment
industry it's very hard to be a one-hit
wonder let's not knock a one-hit wonder
but it's even harder to become an iconic
rock band or hip hop band let's go to
the arts it is very hard to come up with
your Sistine Chapel got it it is even
harder to become a Michelangelo so are
you playing the short game are you
playing the long game this is rule
number two you know or lesson number two
the life has taught me play the long
game aim for legendary don't just say
I'm gonna be world-class in my dominant
pursuit for a little window of time say
I want to have the guts and the grit and
the acumen and the mindset and the
capability and the commitment to create
enduring success and that's why I say
nothing fails like success you look at
the restaurant that is hot in your
neighborhood right now they're on the
path to obsolescence if they're not
really careful sure they went from a
little neighborhood shop that made
beautiful pasta that had great service
that had the owner on the floor shaking
your hand getting to know your name then
they got written up in the magazines and
they then they got interviewed and then
word of mouth spread like wildfire and
what happened
they became arrogant you see success can
be so toxic and it happens it is such a
pull on every human being it just plays
with your mind and you literally shift
from humility to arrogance you shift
from humility to arrogance and once the
arrogance sets in in a mindset it starts
to populate every other person on the
team every other person in the culture
every other person in the community and
it is a very
short fall from success to irrelevance
so lesson number two is nothing fails
like success as you become more
successful become more humble as you
become more successful work even harder
as you become more successful care even
more about your product as you become
more successful learn even more
I invite you it when you are the the
Titan of your industry be sitting in the
room with 18 year olds beginning their
game when you are the the icon of your
field be the person who is up not a five
o'clock anymore let's play at four
o'clock reading listening to the podcast
writing in your journal setting your
goals focusing on your intentions as you
become more successful be more humble as
you become more successful be even more
punctual as you become more successful
become even more passionate as you
become older become even younger
yesterday I was walking on the street
and I met this man in his 80s he said
Robin I finally retired he's probably
close to 90 and he is a legendary
clothier in the country that I live in
and he just retired and he started his
shop which is now an empire in 1954 so I
don't know what that is but that is
decades and decades and decades and
decades
decades and he did not want to retire he
just retired but he is still on fire to
do amazing things
age is just a number do not let an old
person into your body nothing fails like
success I started actually writing a
science fiction novel that had been an
idea I've been playing with a long time
book called Avalon and I was working on
Avalon and it was coming pretty well and
suddenly the first chapter of Game of
Thrones came to me where they find the
dire wolf pups
[Music]
it's a freak
it's a direwolf I knew it wasn't part of
the science fiction not while I was
writing this was clearly a fantasy
medieval had these wolves and this large
family I'd been reading a lot of
historical fiction and I have been in
the back of my mind but suddenly it all
gels and I wrote and I wrote that
chapter in like two three days it just
came to pour out of me goats stop there
are five pups one for each of the stark
children the direwolf is the sigil of
your house they were meant to have them
we'll train them yourselves you'll feed
them yourselves and if they die you'll
bury them yourselves
when I did return the books I said to
myself okay I've had many things option
they never make them I've done pilots
and TV shows tried to keep them within
budget and producible and ever make that
I'm tired of playing that game I'm gonna
you know I have a big imagination I have
an epic story I want to tell I'm gonna
make it as big as my imagination I'm
gonna have all the the castles and
battles I want I'm gonna have hundreds
of characters because the real world is
complex I want my fictional world to be
complex too not as kind of simplified
thing I want to have giant battles I
want to have incredible castles that
each one is distinct from the other that
people remember for all time I want to
have dragons and direwolves and mammoths
and a wall of ice at 700 feet tall I
want something huge and epic that can
stand up there with token